speaking of inflation today we are going
to see comments from jerome powell uh he
is going in front of congress and in
prepared remarks as part of manda
mandated testimony
powell is going to speak about the fed's
economic response to covet powell has
cautioned that the causes of the recent
rise in inflation may last longer than
anticipated i am not going to tell you
that i told you so but i told you so
back in march of last year every
bitcoiner in the world was yelling and
screaming on the internet if you print
all the cash there's going to be
inflation and we were told don't worry
about inflation inflation will not be a
problem shut up you guys are morons you
don't know anything about economics you
don't know anything about wall street
you know anything about asset prices
then
bitcoiners continue to say it over and
over and over and over again you can't
print trillions of dollars you can't do
all this fiscal monetary policy and not
get inflation and then we started to
hear oh inflation may be really far on
the horizon in q3 of last year it's
really far away if we ever see inflation
we'll deal with it then
and then in q4 and into q1 we start to
get a little different story oh that
inflation that we may or may not be
experiencing and it's gonna maybe or
maybe not pick up a little bit it'll be
temporary
and then by june and july
oh my god the inflation is here it's
over five percent we had cpi levels that
were the highest in 13 years we had core
inflation levels at the highest in 30
years and it was way higher than anyone
thought and we got told again it's just
temporary don't worry about it and then
came july and august and the biden
administration literally took their
inflation expectations for q4 of this
year from 2 to 4.8 they more than
doubled their expectation for inflation
but it was still temporary
not so much anymore now we have jerome
powell who is clearly stating that the
recent rise in inflation may last longer
than anticipating this goes back to the
idea the word transitory cannot be
measured how long is it how severe does
it have to be
so what they'll say is oh it's
transitory for a couple more years
i don't know that doesn't fit my
definition of transitory but it may fit
yours and so today at the conclusion of
the policy meeting or i'm sorry at the
policy meeting last wednesday members of
the fed rate setting committee predicted
an annual inflation rate of 4.2 percent
by year end that's up from three point
four percent they were forecasting in
june so in june they thought your end
would be three point four now they're
saying oh wait a second it might be four
point two percent again i'm not a
mathematician but that is about a 20
increase in what they thought the
inflation level would be at the end of
the year in june to what it is now so
they are raising their expectations
which means that if they previously
thought there was going to be a
transitory aspect of inflation or
inflation was going to go down they now
are saying oh we think it might go up
it may be higher than we thought which
means the fed was wrong
and the bitcoiners were right inflation
is here and it is going to be much more
persistent than they previously expected
so they now are saying that don't worry
inflation is expected to cool to about
2.2 percent next year though i'm sure
that they'll never raise those
expectations in the future we'll see so
we got a bunch of quotes the first from
jerome powell federal reserve chairman
he says as the economy continues to
reopen and spending rebounds we are
seeing upward pressure on prices
particularly due to supply bottlenecks
in some sectors these effects have been
larger and longer lasting than
anticipated but they will abate and as
they do inflation is expected to drop
back toward our longer run two percent
goal
the second quote as reopening continues
bottlenecks hiring difficulties and
other constraints could again prove to
be greater and more enduring than
anticipated posing upside risk to
inflation if sustained higher inflation
would become a serious concern we would
certainly respond and use our tools to
ensure that inflation runs at levels
that are consistent with our goals i am
going to call it out right square flat
in the front if you're the leader of an
organization that is responsible for
monetary policy and you go in front of
congress and you say inflation may be
higher but it's all because of supply
chain
it's all because of hiring difficulties
and you don't like a man stand there and
say oh maybe our policies contributed to
this is too you just continue to deflect
any sort of responsibility you take
zero credit for this problem
maybe we need somebody else because that
is what leadership would do is they
would say you know what we made the
decisions that we needed to make and it
helped us prevent the short-term pain
and now what we are seeing is that we
use such extreme measures which were
needed at the time that we were going to
have higher levels of inflation and it's
the combination of supply chain
disruptions hiring difficulties and the
decisions that we made on a monetary
fiscal situation and we have it under
control we understand what's happening
and we will continue to watch it closely
and in the future if we need to make new
decisions we will make those decisions
you can count on us but they lose all
credibility when they refuse to say that
monetary or fiscal policy contributed to
this and they continue to simply point
at and say oh it's a supply chain issue
oh it's hiring difficulties and pretend
like monetary and fiscal policy don't
play into this at all it is complete
nonsense in my opinion
inflation isn't transferred duh
i mean
first let's just start with the fact
that now they're saying that inflation's
higher
are we surprised no
okay do we feel like they can continue
to use the word transitory now no okay i
didn't think they should for the last
whatever period of time either but same
yeah are we concerned with the fact that
he's going in front of congress and he's
basically saying oh it's supply chain
it's hiring like basically it's not us
like but this is like their mo right
like this is what they've been saying
for the last 12 18 months i feel like
the federal reserve got their hand
caught they got caught with their hand
in the cookie jar and now they're like
well i didn't take the cookies like
no literally yes you did you literally
incentivized this entire situation you
can't now pretend you didn't contribute
but like
ultimately right they're either lying or
they're incompetent and don't understand
what's going on with it right and i
don't know which one's worse right
they're both bad so it comes down to
like how are they going to fix it and uh
we've seen from jerome powell that what
was the saying that he said like no
one's coming in his office and telling
him and complaining about it right so uh
we'll see i think people are naive to
think that any of these increasing
prices are gonna come back down right
like we we talked about chipotle a few
weeks ago not only yeah they raised
their uh government they raised their
employee prices but they did that
through raising the prices of all their
goods on their menu right so uh there's
plenty of other examples outside of
chipotle with amazon and all these other
places but these prices aren't coming
back down they may be four or five six
percent today and eventually come back
down to two percent year over year where
uh the fed expects them to be but
they're not returning back to uh to
where they were a year ago or two years
ago so people need to be concerned about
where their purchasing power is going
and it's only going to get worse
he said they're ready to use the tools
that they have available if it does not
uh subside inflation we know those tools
are he's going to use them it's not
gonna help
we have a chart of the monthly 12-month
inflation rate in the united states from
august of 2020 to august of 2021 supply
chain
i mean you could say it's supply chain
sure
but i'm sure supply chain does have
something to do with it of course i
don't think it's only supply chain that
is why prices are up six percent i am a
believer
that
it's everything
combined
not it's this one thing which they
continue to say of supply chains
bottlenecks all these whatever language
they want to use so i'm more of a
mindset of everything plays a piece in a
complex system so if you move monetary
policy lever or you move fiscal policy
lever or you move supply chain lever or
hiring lever whatever the different
things are that all plays a part by the
way new house plays a part do the are
unemployment benefits increased or not
are people paying out or not for example
uh in new york city they have now fired
health care workers who refuse to get
the vaccine
and the new york board of labor
has refused to pay those health care
workers unemployment insurance
from what i from what i was reading
nice so
thousands of people around the country
are being fired because they wouldn't
get the vacation health professionals
being fired because they won't get the
vaccine which again their their choice
whatever you can believe that uh the
vaccine works and that people should
have their own choice i think that
that's fair
but then we're saying oh by the way
you're not going to get on insurance uh
you're not going to get unemployment
which is afforded to every single other
person in the country who uh qualifies
for and so when you start to look at
this stuff you say that also has an
impact right whether we're giving this
stuff to people or we're not and i think
that what
is really scary is this is a confidence
game they can't just come out and say
you know what
don't worry about it uh
we don't really know what's going on but
i promise that we're going to solve it
instead of what they have to do is they
have to present the fact that they know
what they're doing whether that's true
or not and so later on you just simply
say oh inflation's gonna be a little bit
higher than we thought some things
changed we changed our mind no problem
and everyone kind of just writes it off
as again part of the charade but nobody
actually believed in my opinion that
inflation was really not going to show
up at a high rate after you print
trillions and trillions of dollars hey
guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from so
far not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com pomp download the app and go
ahead and open an account sofi.com
and make sure you come back and watch
more of the best business show we're
going to build the biggest business show
in the world and we need your help